toujours au chapitre judiciaire devant
la cour de cassation l'éventuelle
révision de la condamnation de patrick
dils condamné il ya onze ans pour le
meurtre de deux enfants cette requête en
révision amènerait à considérer que le
tueur en série francis heaulme présent à
l'époque des faits sur les lieux du
crime pourraient en être l'auteur
valérie ermite christian galley pour les
familles des victimes
c'est une large blessure qui s'ouvre à
nouveau pour les parents de patrick dils
c'est en revanche le dernier espoir de
voir peut-être un jour leur fils
innocente est très important de votre
vie puis ce fut de l'avis de patrick ont
représenté vendus en 1986 alexandre et
cyril et 8 ans ont retrouvé mort frappé
très violemment à coups de pierres le
long d'une voie ferrée
sept mois plus tard patrick dils alors
âgé de 16 ans passent aux aveux des
aveux très précis très détaillé le jeune
il se rétractera par la suite pour
clamer son innocence mais sera condamnée
à la perpétuité en 1989
ce n'est que huit ans plus tard que l'on
apprendra que francis heaulme
aujourd'hui célèbre tueur en série a
croisé les enfants à l'heure du crime
même s'il nie les avoir tués un élément
nouveau très important pour l'avocate
générale mais qui ne suffit pas à
disculper patrick dils en revanche elle
demande un supplément d'information et
une analyse adn sur les pierres qui ont
servi à tuer est parfait puisque
bannière ça ne pourra aboutir à ce que
l'on me dit depuis maintenant trois ans
quatre ans patrick dit innocent pensée
sur les coupables
donc l'adn c'est une excellente idée
c'est encore possible vous savez ont
prié le se sont encore techniquement
possible qu'on vienne pas dire que c'est
une erreur judiciaire sonné on n'a pas
de parti pris pour ce gars là ce serait
un autre qui l'aurait fait c'est pareil
mais tout de même on peut pas dire que
c'est pas lui quand c'est lui avec leurs
convictions respectives
les familles sont parties chacune de
leur côté la justice décidera le 28 juin
en du sort de patrick dils
c'est des gens soit presque une première
en onze ans la cour de révision n'a
statué qu'une seule fois en matière
criminelle